hi everyone this is feeder master
coaster kabuki here for chess calm and
today I'm going to be showing you guys
the ins and outs of the Catalan opening
so the Catalan is reached through the
Queen's Gambit decline which I've
actually already covered here on our
YouTube channel so night of three night
of six and now this move g3 it's
important that white first develops
their Knight to f3 and leaves the Queen
night here on b1 and the reason is that
this Knight doesn't always go to c3
sometimes in the Catalan we're going to
develop this Knight to d2 or even to a3
and I'll explain why a little later on
but it's important to make sure that we
can keep our development as flexible as
possible but the main point of the
Cataline is that we're putting our King
Bishop on this long diagonal here
instead of its normal spot in the Queens
gambit declined which is e2 or d3 and
the reason we want to put our Bishop on
g2 is that this Bishop is going to be
really good at exerting pressure in the
center and all the way to black's Queen
side so this is sort of another way of
playing the Queen's Gambit is playing
the cattle and opening rather than the
traditional sort of classical way of
playing it with moves like Knight c3
Bishop g5 and then III and Bishop d3 so
against the Catalan black typically has
two main ways of responding to it and
Black's biggest decision here is whether
they want to capture this pawn on c4 or
leave their pawn solid on d5 in the
center so capturing the pawn on c4 would
lead to what is known as the open
Catalan and leaving the pawn on d5 would
be the closed Catalan so let's take a
look and see what happens if black
chooses not to take this pawn
for and just continues his development
so Bishop g2 castles and castles so
blacks main problem in pretty much all
Queens gambit declined openings is the
LightSquared Bishop they need to find a
way to develop this bishop and you know
finish their Queen side development a
good way to do that in the close Catalan
is to complete the development through
moves like c6 and b6 and putting this
Bishop either on b7 or even a six and
then the Queens Knight is going to come
to d7 and the rook to c8 and eventually
black is going to try to play this move
c5
so meanwhile while black is doing all
this stuff White's plan is typically to
try to play this movie for and open up
the long diagonal and open up the center
where White has more control and up and
a slight space advantage so let's say
black plays 97 and now a good move would
be something like Queen c2 and the Queen
is usually very nicely placed on c2
because now we're protecting our pawn on
c4 and we're supporting a future efore
and now let's say c6 Knight b d2 and b6
and now it's time for white to play e4
and a lot of games go like this and we
reach a position that's very much
playable for both sides probably why it
is slightly better because blacks
position is a little bit passive but
many many good players play this way for
black and it's considered a very solid
opening against the the catalan and now
black takes this pawn on e4 after we do
trades and black plays Bishop d7 to
protect the c6 pawn generally white is
always going to be better in these kinds
of positions because this Bishop on b7
is almost always going to remain passive
so like a move
rook d1 is pretty good and eventually
black needs to play this move c5 to
challenge white center and open up this
Bishop and what needs to be able to
respond to that move with d5 and this
will give white more space and a
possible initiative in the center
black's other option here to this movie
for is just to ignore this pawn and then
develop the bishop try there b7 or a six
I think a six is definitely the more
active spot for the bishop so let's just
assume black plays the bishop to a6 and
then white should grab more space with E
5 and play this move rook e1 and the
point of this move is that White's going
to use this F 1 square to maneuver their
pieces two better squares like the
knight come to F 1 and then to e3 where
it exerts more force on the center and
also the bishop can sometimes go to f1
into d3 where it can attack blacks King
side black's plan in these kinds of
positions is always put the rook on ca
and then try to play c5 and try to
disrupt white strong center and if
they're able to do all of that then they
usually get very good counter play and
this night on e 8 will probably come to
c7 where it can support the d5 and d6
squares so blacks other option when
faced with the catalan is to take this
pawn on c4 and this is definitely a
sharper way to play for black and if
you're looking to establish a quality
right out of the opening or even try to
create some kind of problem for white
and I definitely recommend you consider
this move D takes c4 because white
cannot really immediately capture this
pawn or when his pawn back if they want
to play for any sort of
energy they can play move like Queen a4
check and then take this pawn but they
wasted a little bit of time in the
opening moving their Queen and black is
going to be able to develop very easily
with a move like a six and the point of
this move is to play b5 hitting the
Queen with a tempo and then developing
the Bishop to b7 and once black gets
this Bishop to b7 opposing White's
Bishop on G to black is usually going to
be okay because none of his pieces are
going to be passive and eventually he's
going to play c5 and challenge the
center and get good counter play in the
center and out of the opening I mean
there's not a whole lot more you could
really ask for with the black pieces
other than getting all your pieces
developed and having good control over
the center so this is not really what
white wants to do when playing the
Catalan the more aggressive option and
more ambitious option is to just
continue their development and try to
create some kind of pressure along the
long diagonal and now you're black sort
of has another choice they can try to
hold on to this pawn or they can just
leave this pawn on c4 and count on the
fact that eventually White's going to
have to spend time taking it either with
Queen c2 and Queen c4 or 92 and Knight
takes e4 and while white is spending a
bit of time recapturing this pawn then
black can complete his development and
play c5 and try to get counter play for
example a really solid option here is
something like Bishop e7 castles castles
Queen c2 and now a6 and again the point
of this move is that black gets to put
their Bishop on b7 where it challenges
White's strong bishop on g2 and as
you've probably already guessed this
Bishop on g2 is White's best piece
so getting the bishop to be seven is a
good achievement for black and general
in these kinds of positions it's all
about whether black can comfortably play
c5 so white is going to try to stop
black from playing c5 with moves like
rook d1 possibly a 3 and B 4 or 92 and
93 and black is going to try to get this
move c5 in with moves like 97 and rook
c8 right and if black can play c5 then
his position won't really be passive and
his chances will be just as good as
whites on the other hand if y can stop
this move c5 then black is always going
to have this weakness on the C file that
Y could later target in some kind of
endgame or late middle game position so
that's a very solid way for blacks to
continue and most likely they'll
probably equalize if they play you know
relatively good moves later on a much
sharper approached and all of that is to
try to hold on to this pawn through some
kind of a 6 + b5 plan but of course this
is very risky because if black is
wasting time playing moves like a6 and
b5 this early on they are neglecting
their development so for example b5 is a
move that they can play and if you're
playing the Catalan is white and your
opponent is trying to set up these pawns
on the light squares and hold on to his
extra pawn on c4 there are a couple of
different ways you can sort of challenge
this formation the most common way is to
play the move a4 and what this does is
white is just trying to break up black's
pawn structure so now black takes is
pawn then after white recaptures and why
it's going to take this pawn next black
is left with these two weak pawns on the
Queen side which isn't very good and
white definitely has an advantage here
because they're going to be able to
target these pawns later on
so typically black has to play something
here like c6 and of course move like a6
doesn't work because of this pin along
the
Filan black can't recapture because this
rook is hanging so c6 and now a move
like 95 is very common here opening up
the bishop on the long diagonal using
the knight to pressure c6 and more often
than not black is forced to block this
diagonal with this night and then why
can castle if it should be 7 as a normal
move and why can do something like efore
Knight f6 Knight c3 and what's going on
here is that white is down upon and
they're probably not going to win this
pawn back soon but White's compensation
is that he has very good development and
very good control over the center and a
lot of times white is looking for this
breakthrough d5 okay when you're up in
development and you have good control
over the center you want to break open
the center because then your pieces will
open up and since you're better
developed your pieces will be able to
cause more damage to your opponent's
position so that's one way of sort of
playing this line probably safer for
black is to start with this move a six
and then after white castles do
something like knight c6 so black is
developing and at the same time he's
getting ready to play b5 to support this
pawn and now again why does a couple of
different ways to sort of play this
position one idea is just to play Knight
c3 and then efore and just try to
eventually create some kind of attack
either in the center or even on the King
side based on having these strong pawns
on d4 and e4 another idea that's
probably a more modern way of playing
the system is to play e3 and the idea
behind this move is that white wants to
just finish his development with Queen
e2 rook d1 and at some point just play
this move b3 which will allow black to
keep as extra pawn for example something
like Bishop d7 and a move like this is
necessary because any time black wants
to play b5 in this
position they're going to have to reckon
with 95 which is very hard to meet
actually black here is already losing
some kind of material based on this pin
along the diagonal so Bishop d7 sort of
is preparing b5 Queenie to be 5 and now
b3 and the point is that after black
takes and white takes black is going to
have an extra pawn for a long time but
why it is going to be able to slowly
build up pressure so it moves like
Bishop b2 rook FC 1 and then either
night a3 or 92 are very natural and
white can build a pressure along the C
and open a file as well as with moves
like a 4 or 95 and so on and so forth so
to sum up the catalan is really a very
interesting opening for both sides
because white is essentially trying to
build a strong center and use this
powerful bishop along the long diagonal
another line I should mention here is
that a very common move here for black
is C 5 and the point of this move is
that they're just immediately trying to
strike back a white center and now
castles is normal knight c6 and here y
can even play a move like D takes e5
giving up control over the center but
this is still fighting for an advantage
because white is going to try to prove
that his bishop on g2 is better than
blacks bishop on c8 so something like
Queen d1 rook d1 Bishop c5 and 92 and
White's idea is that he wants to win
this pawn back and then have this very
nice Bishop on g2 against this Bishop on
CA which a lot of times is going to be
stuck defending this b7 pawn and you
know passive pieces in the endgame is
really bad
but I can still probably play for
equality here it's definitely always
going to be slightly better for white
but it is an endgame and black should be
able to have enough resources to to hold
the draw
and a good move here is to place III
giving the pawn back but at the same
time weakening White's pawn structure
and next block is going to Castle and
play Bishop d7 and bring both of their
rooks to the center and why it's going
to play Bishop b2 Knight B 3 and C 4 and
try to create some kind of pressure on
the Queen side and that's pretty much
the point of the Catalan is that white
wants to pressure the Queen side using
this strong Bishop on g2 and try to use
this small space advantage and and C
file sometimes to cause problems and try
to get slight advantage that they can
press on for a while into the endgame
thanks a lot for listening
and I'll see you around on chess calm